what should we do
begin the next game
squid game may have reached global
success but along the way they made some
changes some that went well and others
that have only garnered more criticism
when did you realize
the show became so big right now
when squid game came out and its
popularity began to rise one would think
that the hard work was over but that
wasn't the case with the netflix hit the
show faced serious backlash because the
numbers used on the squid game business
cards were real and belonged to some
residents in south korea if those people
didn't know what squid game was before
they definitely knew when their phones
were blowing up with messages and phone
calls from fans of the kdrama a dessert
shop owner in south korea saw the
effects squid game had on fans pretty
directly her business number was one of
the few shown on screen in the show she
started getting endless phone calls 24
hours a day it's not all jokes though
some of the callers were actually asking
to be part of the game or just to
express their anger and yell
the shop owner had over 4 000 different
numbers trying to reach her clogging up
her business line and affecting her
sugar-free sweet bean jelly's sales
another number belonged to a man who
received so many calls and messages that
his phone was regularly dying throughout
the day not only that he couldn't even
get any of the calls or messages that
were actually meant for him while
netflix worked quickly to edit and cut
scenes where the real phone numbers
appeared for some reason they do still
make the screen for australian viewers
once the show had finished filming the
time came for it to be dubbed over in
different languages one of the actors
who performed the english dubbing was a
big fan of the fact that all his cast
mates were either of korean or asian
heritage which turned out to be a huge
plus when they were recording in the
studio as they came across some
inconsistencies and mistranslations
throughout the script they took a moment
to bring it to the production crew and
change the already written script the
cast did a great job at bringing clarity
to the scenes korean actors even if not
fluent can call out something if it's
not right is how edward hong who did the
dubbing for the priest character put it
he had a better understanding of
specifically how certain people would
speak like the religious character he
portrayed meaning he was able to tell if
something didn't quite click dubbing is
a very specific skill on its own since
the actors need to vocally match the
on-screen performance and visuals so to
be able to change dialogue on the go is
really raising the bar
it's our time to face the lord
while loads of people around the globe
love squid game not everyone is a fan of
what turned out to be some pretty
misleading subtitles when it came to the
english version on netflix translating a
show from its original language is a
tricky job and unfortunately in the case
of squid game many of the subtleties and
meanings were lost in translation which
does do quite a disservice to the
original writer who put together such a
tight script not only that the english
dubbing and the english subtitles also
have variations between them making it a
pretty strange watching experience
i'm better than you think and i'm
stronger than most guys too number two
on two's character was majorly impacted
by this the english translation we get
is
i'm not a genius but i still got it
where it goes when in reality she's
saying i'm very smart i just never got a
chance to study the meanings are pretty
different and the actual line also works
as a reference to a trope of characters
with smarts but not a whole lot of money
that's regularly seen in korean
television
these changes from the original script
didn't work out so well
i'll do anything you tell me i'm not a
regular girl
episode 1 of squid game is called red
light green light but in korean it's a
very different story the original title
of the episode translates to the day
that the mugunga flower blossomed a play
on the name of the game in korea it's a
long but beautiful title and it
definitely isn't even close to the
english one we got what makes this
really frustrating is that we lose a lot
of cultural significance since the
mungungua flower symbolizes beginnings
and is the national flower of korea
depending on who you're talking to or
where you are squid game can also be
referred to as round six it's even the
official title of the show on imdb round
six was the name the show was called
when netflix announced the production in
2019 but when it was time to launch the
show they went with the title we've all
come to hear so often
what we see on screen in the subtitles
and what we hear are two very different
things when it comes to the english
translations if watching the show in
korean the english subtitles don't
feature a small but significant line in
which player 1 says there is no
ownership between me and you the fact
that the subtitles were changed not to
include it deeply affects how we
interpret this
definitely not a great change
on the road to worldwide success
netflix's squid game definitely hits
some speed bumps with the data leaking
and misleading translations but it
hasn't held back the team at all in fact
one change made on the go brought one of
the greatest small moments in the show
guillen picking up sebioc's coffee cup
was total improv
considering it took 10 years for the
show to actually get made it seems like
all the time money and effort was
definitely worth it
what would you do if your number was the
one featured on squid game